una escena que se repite una y otra vez
en california hogares reducidos a
cenizas miles de personas y enfrentan
las secuelas del incendio kaldor uno de
los nuevos focos de preocupación de las
autoridades vientos fuertes y cambiantes
además de una vegetación seca fueron el
combustible perfecto para que la
conflagración se propagara miles de
hectáreas en las montañas al este
sacramento la capital del estado esto en
un periodo menor a 24 horas habitantes
de una de las comunidades más afectadas
chrysler flatts se encuentran en la
incertidumbre mientras esperan poder
regresar a sus hogares o lo que queda de
ellos
mi hogar era todo era perfecto estado
allí por 20 años si tengo suerte tendré
un hogar a dónde ir o tal vez una
oportunidad de reconstruir
los bomberos luchan tratando de contener
las llamas de caldo que empezaron a
arder el 14 de agosto este incendio ya
ha consumido más de 21.000 hectáreas es
importante que todos los californianos
entiendan la severidad de cómo las
condiciones climáticas se alteran el
ambiente y contribuyen a la expansión de
estos incendios haciéndolos más
complejos y más peligrosos que cualquier
cosa que hemos enfrentado en el pasado a
tan solo 161 kilómetros al norte de
calders se encuentra dixie el segundo
incendio más grande en la historia de
california este solo se ha logrado
controlar en un 33 por ciento ha
consumido unos 1200 hogares y amenaza a
unas 16.000 edificaciones